[Musique]
bonsoir Anthony bonsoir à tous on va
reparler de l'Ukraine l'armée russe a
détruit du matériel de l'OTAN déployé en
Ukraine cette affirmation elle émane de
plusieurs comptes Twitter et Facebook
via notamment une publication comme
celle-ci qui circule depuis deux jours
regardez alors même on le sait que la
livraison d'arme lourdes à l'Ukraine des
pays de l'OTAN ne cesse de faire débat
cette vidéo qui cumule plus de 90 000
vues au total ce sont trois minutes
d'image où on voit donc des missiles
qu'est-ce qui s'apparente à des missiles
détruire des hélicoptères en vol des
tanks au sol aussi et puis ce
commentaire de
nous dire que ces bâtiments militaires
n'ont pas résisté à l'assaut de missiles
russe et même de s'étonner qu'aucun
medera occidental ne se sont nos sens
soit fait l'écho contrairement à leur
confrères chinois oui ça c'est la phrase
en général qui nous fait dresser
l'oreille ces images elles sont tout
droit sorties d'un jeu vidéo
effectivement ArmA 3 pour être précis je
ne sais pas si vous connaissez mais il y
avait déjà plusieurs indices sonores
puisque il y avait la musique les
bruitages qui pouvaient mettre la puce à
l'oreille quand à l'authenticité de ces
images c'est vrai il faut bien le dire
assez réaliste la recherche d'image
inversée à laquelle on est bien habitué
maintenant nous renvoie vers plusieurs
vidéos de cette arme à 3 et c'est en
ajoutant sur Youtube ces trois mots ArmA
3 hélicoptères missiles que l'on
retrouve la vidéo en question elle est
ici plus précisément là et voilà les
images d'origine cette destruction donc
de l'hélicoptère que l'on a vu tout à
l'heure vidéo qui date du 7 avril
dernier s'agit donc bien d'une
simulation
issue d'ArmA droit rien à voir avec la
destruction du matériel de l'OTAN par là
en Russie et figurez-vous que la guerre
en Ukraine qui on le rappelle a commencé
le 24 février bien depuis le début de
cette guerre ce n'est pas une première
si bien que le compte Twitter de la
Société des créateurs avaient déjà émis
un avertissement
lendemain de la guerre en Ukraine du
début de la guerre en Ukraine quant aux
utilisations détournées de leur jeu et
les images dont on parle ce soir elles
ont également été utilisées en 2018 pour
faire croire une attaque de drone turc
en série c'est à dire et avoir sur le
site des Observateurs de France 24
images très réaliste en tout cas autre
preuve avancée de destruction du
matériel de l'OTAN par la Russie un
entrepôt en flamme effectivement cette
image à regarder que l'on regardait que
l'on retrouve sur plusieurs comptes
Facebook il s'agit d'un dépôt d'armes de
l'OTAN détruit à nicolaef nicolaïve en
ukrainien au sud de l'Ukraine en
procédant là encore à une image une
recherche d'images inversée avec cette
publication en fait on tombe sur
différents tweets avec la même image
mais pas la même légende ici on nous
parle de terminale céréalier de dépôt
d'entrepôts de céréales c'est également
le cas ici où on nous parle de réserve
de graines ou encore de blé
ukrainien alors armes de l'OTAN ou
céréales pour en savoir plus il faut
aller sur Google chercher des images de
la ville de mikolaif et plus précisément
du port de Nick catera c'est ici au sud
le point rouge que l'on voit sur cette
carte ça nous renvoie sur différents
articles qui vont nous renseigner sur
l'activité du port en question et on
apprend ainsi et bien quand en 2020 par
exemple quand 2020
76% des marchandises qui est
transitaient étaient des céréales ça
nous donne donc un indice et d'autres
articles de l'époque nous renseignent
aussi sur la construction dans ce même
port d'un nouveau terminal entièrement
dédié au stockage de céréales et en
comparant les photos à celles de la
publication virale on peut trouver
plusieurs éléments qui coïncident et
jusqu'à preuve du contraire et bien les
sirènes ne sont pas des armes de l'OTAN
une arme en revanche peut-être utilisée
par la Russie en tout cas
vraisemblablement utilisé par la Russie
parce que ces images et bien ce sont
celles du bombardement russe il y a du
jour du terminal céréalier du port de
nicolaïf le deuxième d'Ukraine à
contribuer évidemment à une aggravation
de la crise alimentaire mondiale et qui
a valu d'ailleurs un bombardement à la
condamnation du chef de la diplomatie
européenne merci beaucoup Anthony Saint
Léger vous restez avec nous on se
retrouve dans quelques instants pour un
nouveau journal dans ce Paris direct à
tout de suite
[Musique]